about statistics and perfection it's
nice of you here
I am currently starting to work my way
into privacy I've been really delving
into it
for the over the past couple of months
my background is statistics and more
specifically robust statistics and so
when I arrived at Penn State I saw some
connections between all possible
connections between robust statistics
and and privacy and so I started working
on some ideas and this is more or less
an overview of these ideas and some
possible preliminary results that could
help improve the usefulness of
statistical accuracy of the outputs so
the idea are well the connections
between robust statistics and
differential privacy well now are not
new there's the first as to my knowledge
first paper that underlined this link
was Dworkin they where they use robust
statistics as a basis for a proposed
test release algorithm then they focuses
on M estimators for using perturb data
and more recent one was a child Orion
sue who used a robust robustness measure
to study the convergence rates of
differentially private's outputs towards
in terms of approximations to statistics
so along this line this talk aims at
understanding if some tools that are
existing the robust statistics and in
bias correction can help in terms of
preserving differential privacy
I say pure differential privacy and if
you improve at the same time improve the
statistical accuracy of the these
differentially products outputs so the
first thing is the first idea is using M
estimation as laded so
the idea is we define an estimator that
will generate call T and we define it as
an MS tomater which we'll see later what
an M estimator is and apply a bounded
function to it which is something that's
commonly done in the robust literature
robust statistics and thanks to this
bound we can deliver results there's a
natural result in terms of the
sensitivity of the resulting estimator
and that can of course be helpful in
determining the amount of noise to be
added for the differential price output
and therefore there can be a kind of
trade-off between the bound you put on
your M estimator and the accuracy of
your differential price output a second
idea that I wants to go or test today
was understanding how some ideas some
recent ideas from statistics in terms of
bias correction can help improving the
statistical accuracy of differential
deprives outputs so the first idea is
actually was an idea that was left lying
around since 1995 it's called I tilted
bootstrap and that was proposed by Cooke
and recently paper has shown that this
method can correct finite sample and
their proper and asymptotic bias exactly
in many cases under certain conditions
and therefore this procedure can
eventually be used to correct the bias
of differentially of biased
differentially private releases and so
that's one method that I will be
actually using today within the the
results I'll be discussing a second one
is very much related to the talk and
given earlier on confidence intervals so
what is what kind of inference
so once I've released my private outputs
how can I perform tests to understand
I'll retrieve information regarding
parameters or information from my
original data and this is another recent
approach that allows to deliver an
inference framework at very little cost
in terms of mathematical developments so
given that this is the these are the
goals so I'll briefly introduce what
robust statistics is from my perspective
so discussing with so you what comes
that I think came out is that my
background in robustness is not
necessarily the same kind of your
business that maybe is known within
differential privacy or as well in other
areas of Statistics so I'll first
underline what my my background and my
perception of robust statistics is then
I'll be giving a brief idea of what
these as I call post processing
mechanism survice correction and switch
their estimation for inference and then
I'll just give some results of a very
simple simulation setting where I do I
use objective perturbation for
differential privacy and analyze how the
robust solutions with the i30 bootstrap
can help help improve the statistical
accuracy of the outputs and then
conclusions of possible feature work
okay so any if there are any questions
please stop me whenever you want okay so
the background that I come from for
robust statistics is is this one what
you assume so maybe one way to look at
it is say you want to generate some
synthetic data and you you have a
generating model for your synthetic data
and this can be univariate or
multivariate data okay and so let's say
that this model we call f theta where
theta is the parameter of interest that
defines your model so what robustness
says or reverse statistic says is that
this model is at best an approximation
of reality okay so it's all models are
wrong but some are useful so suppose
assuming that my data comes from this
model is an approximation so how and
what we observe in reality is a
contaminated version of this model that
we assume so
robustness starts from this setting
saying okay my data comes from yes it
comes from the model F Peter but it a
certain proportion of it which is small
Delta comes from a certain other
distribution or other model G now G for
purposes of robustness robust statistics
is left unspecified we don't want to
specify what G is we're just interested
in our data generating model F visa
which is contaminated with G okay so
we're interested in the parameter theta
okay
so given that we don't want to specify
what G is the issue is how do we deal or
identify the observations or so-called
outliers that come from this
distribution because in some way we'd
like to be able to identify them and
therefore if we manage to identify them
we can get rid of them and at that point
perform normal analysis on data that
comes from F theta problem is in many
cases it's very hard to identify
outliers so it's especially in highly
structured data or high dimensional data
you don't exactly know what an outlier
is and if you perform a certain kind of
removal of your outliers
this can highly impact the inference and
estimation and inference procedure you
perform afterwards so when you perform
tests based on your estimations these
could be very wrong so the idea of
robust statistics is okay let's I want
to study and reduce the impact of
outliers on my estimation procedure so
whatever statistic I'm computing on my
data I want to reduce the impact of
outliers on it and once I've done this I
want to have an appropriate framework
where I can have my point estimate and I
can perform my inference saying testing
whether a certain hypothesis about my
data is true or not
okay so to do that robust statistics
proposes some measures and so it and it
measures how much certain statistic or
certain operation you do on your data
how much it it is impacted by outliers
so the the this connection was already
made IND wark and and in these papers
saying what is the impact of a data
point the changes on the operation I
make so the algorithm or estimator so in
order to study this impact robust
statistics just users or defines an
estimator or statistic whatever you
compute as a functional T so an
estimated T can be expressed as a
functional saying that it depends on my
underlying distribution F through the
data X so you can say that my estimator
is a function of my empirical
distribution function f of n and for
example the sample mean can be expressed
as a functional this way so I just say
that the sample mean is this functional
here okay
so it's just a way to express estimators
in a way that can be studied as we'll
see later on in the robust framework so
if there any questions please go ahead
so first measure this is used and which
starts to indicate the proximity
eventual proximity of robustness and
privacy is the sensitivity curve so this
function is defined as follows so
suppose we have
n minus-1 fixed observations that we put
into a univariate setting okay so we put
all these n minus ones observations into
this vector and we add an F observation
which we call x0 and this observation is
allowed to move along the entire real
line so the sensitivity curve is defined
as this standardized difference between
the functional or estimator or algorithm
applied to the X mine and minus one
vector with x0 with the estimator
algorithm applied to only the x xn minus
1 okay so if you work out if you define
what the estimator is for example sample
mean has this sensitivity curve and so
basically what that means is this
sensitivity curve is directly
proportional to X 0 and therefore if X 0
goes to infinity so does my sensitivity
curve so in this case the sample mean
for this version of this reversal
robustus measure is unbounded so what
the measure that's actually very much
used is that in Reverse statistics is
the influence function which is
basically in very loosely speaking
asymptotic version so when n goes to
infinity
it's an asymptotic version of the
sensitivity curve so basically we have
our contamination model except that in
this case we specify that G is a point
mass distribution in X 0 so X 0 is this
point that can move along the Attar we
align and Delta X 0 is the probability
mass the point mass distribution in that
point so we said earlier that robustness
doesn't want to specify what that
contamination is but it does so in this
case because it is proven that the
maximum bias that an estimator can
undergo in terms of contamination is
exactly the point mass so the influence
function is basically studying the
maximal possible influence of all bias
induced by an outlying on
vation okay and so based on this
definition the influence function is
expressed as this ghetto derivative with
respect to the contamination
distribution where this implies limits
from the right
okay so Delta is going to 0 from the
right and if you just do the same as a
fourth sample mean for example the
influence function is not surprising me
this guy here and of course we can see
mu is the actual location parameter that
maybe we want to estimate and x0 is
which is fixed and x0 is allowed to vary
so sensitivity curve the influence
function of the mean is unbounded when
you apply T to a distribution except
this area you're taking it as sum is it
steep how steep so so T is so an
estimator or you can see as being a
function of your data so the mean for
example is a is a is a function of your
data with it which is itself a function
of an underlying distribution so let's
say they come from a normal T can be
seen as a function of the normal
distribution and this case it's the
empirical distribution so it's based on
data based based on the empirical
distribution and it converges towards
there's an assumed connection between
how it behaves on finite samples and how
it behaves on sort of when the argument
is yes exactly so you're assuming that
that your well it that's again that's a
kind of discussion on the properties of
your estimator so you're a face the
sample mean then we know that T of F n
converges to T of F and therefore is
consistent estimator of almonds yeah
exactly so we're not specifying whether
or not this is a consistent estimator or
not we're just saying that we can
express it as a function of my
underlying distribution through my data
and we're not assuming for the moment
we're not assuming anything if then once
we express what functional it is we can
study its properties and understand in
whether it's consistent with respect to
a certain assumption so yeah I don't
know if I so it flips function so in in
in this case in this case the influence
function is a measure that's commonly
used in robust statistics to understand
if to define whether an estimator or
whether certain functional is robust or
not and so another measure with and this
is the last one is the gross error
sensitivity which is simply the supremum
in at zero of my inference function and
so an estimator a or T is considered or
defined as being robust if it's
influence function is bounded and
therefore a which implies that also my
gross error sensitivity is bounded so
this measure this grocery sensitivity
was actually used within inland paper of
Choudary and su in 2012 as a way to
study the convergence rate of
differentially private approximations to
estimators so that's the the connection
well that's one of the connections to
two differential privacy so basically
this is measuring you can see this as
measuring the maximum amount of
influence that one observation can have
on my estimator or interpreted as being
algorithm okay so it's basically so
given that I'm YouTube to privacy I'm
supposing it's related to the concept of
the sensitivity of of the algorithm yes
we should think about this as local
so I'm yes Massa fix F Sarah yes this is
perfect that pacer so and if it
correspond guess it's I I think it
corresponds to the definition of locals
yeah okay
so so yeah so that's more as the the
framework wherein so the background of
robust statistics now the idea is okay
for robust statistics we want to define
functionals T statistics or algorithms
that respect this condition ie whose
influence function is bounded so one of
the main tools used for this purpose is
the framework of M estimation so let's
define the functional T as being an M
estimator so and define as the
minimization of this convex problem so
we want to find the parameter theta
which is of interest based on minimizing
this convex function okay so this is a
very general expression many problems
can be written in this way as we'll see
later on and as you probably already
know and we can express this M estimator
and it's often used in robustness to
express it in a different way is simply
to define it as the zero solution zero
of a certain score functions I website
is the derivative of my convex function
with respect to the parameter of
interest okay so basically we either
find theta that minimizes row or we find
feature that makes this argument zero so
if we if we go to a standard statistical
background the M&E the maximum
likelihood estimator can be expressed as
an M estimator so you take you're
assuming a distribution for your data
where F small F represents the density
function of your data
and defined by the parameter theta that
you're interested in take the log of
that likelihood function is negative and
you minimize that so that's a maximum
likelihood estimation so that's in that
case the royal function is is this
function here and alternatively you can
express it as the auxiliary with respect
to theta of this function here okay so
in this case we of course if theta is
has dimension P larger than one this is
a system of score functions okay you
need to find the zero of solutions here
to all of them now another example is
which is what we'll be looking at in the
simulation results what the premiere
simulation results is this location
parameter problem so say we wanted to
find our distribution is f and it's
centered around theta what say we wanted
to find theta well to find theta and we
can define it as an MS eMeter where we
just say okay it's Rho of X minus theta
or alternatively as the solution is zero
and so if we define role as being Y
squared of 2 then this just goes back
down to finding the stamp sample mean
for normal distribution if we define Rho
as being the absolute function then this
corresponds to the median so it's a
generalization or certain estimators so
given given this what happens with with
the properties of these SM estimators
with respect to the RUS robustness
measures as defined earlier well
remember we wanted to ban the influence
function which corresponds to bounding
the system where there's local
sensitivity
well we for an M estimator the influence
function is defined this way where this
term B is simply a constant and
expectation which is based on the
parameter so and this is this part is
the only part that
on my point mass distribution x0 and so
we can see that the influence function
of an M estimator is directly
proportional to this size function the
score function okay so if we have a
bounded score function our M estimator
is robust and therefore its sensitivity
is bounded so that's basically robust
statistics make good use of M estimation
since when they use bounded functions
for this society in order to bound them
okay so what's our what's our the
solutions so there's the various
functions that are used to bound this
score function so if we go back here we
could just say that this guy is X minus
theta squared and therefore here we just
have two times X minus theta as being
the score function so what do we do 2x
minus theta is not bounded so we apply a
bounded function to it because we know
that the expectation of the my score
function is zero so I know that I want
to find a solution in a proximity of
zero okay so the idea for example one
commonly used bounded function is
hoover's the family of Hueber functions
and it's defined in this manner so
within a certain distance K of my
solution which is in 0i i defined the
score the the role function as being the
same as my so it's so it's basically the
quadratic solution of least square or
least square problem and then it becomes
linear so what what does that mean it's
derivative is is bounded because it's
bounded between K and minus K okay so
when if this tuning constant K which
determines where we want to cut around
zero when it goes to infinity
with this this is simply a corresponds
to the sample mean if it goes to zero
then we have the median okay and so this
is just a representation of these two
functions so this is the convex function
row that we want to minimize
so it's quadratic and then it becomes a
linear outside of K and then so if K
goes to infinity all this function just
becomes quadratic and so that just
becomes the sample mean if this goes to
zero it becomes linear and so we have
another one complex at one problem and
so in this case the original as you can
see the derivative is bounded between
these two values determined by K so the
idea is we apply a bounded function in
order to bound the sensitivity and the
inference function of my estimator or my
algorithm okay so given this the the
issue with doing this is is the
following your school function let's
take this this guy so if we're
estimating a location parameter we we
can say okay my school function is two
times X minus theta and Peter's what I
want to estimate so want to find theta
that minimizes that this sum okay the
problem is if I apply the weight I saw
here it's a symmetric weight so
basically what I'm doing is I'm if X
comes from an asymmetric distribution
I'm basically cutting off values that
actually are quite informative and so
I'm cutting around to the center and
throwing away in Porton information on
one side so what this does is introduce
bias in robust estimation so often M
estimators are defined through a bounded
function plus a correction term to
remove the bias and so this is just
stating that this correct
term is often needed according to the
problem you have and but this is a
problem that is often quite complicated
solved because it depends on the assumed
underlying distribution for your data
and therefore it's on a case-by-case
basis okay so one solution that says
recently proposed and now I come to the
post processing mechanisms is the
following so we have let's say we have
an estimator or an algorithm T and we
denote it as as follows as PI hat which
depends on the data which depends on my
true underlying parameter theatres I'll
call that theta 0 my true parameter okay
and so of course we it's not an explicit
function of this we we don't observe fit
0 but it's there's a link between the
auxiliary estimator and theta 0 so
basically PI hats can be my robust
function my near score my robust Hall
function bounded applied to an
exponential distribution which is
therefore which will therefore give a
biased estimator of the mean so ok so
this is a biased estimator I'd like to
correct it IIE I'd like to find an
unbiased solution to theta 0 okay so the
idea comes from this I chose to
bootstrap where basically I define this
is the auxilary estimator computers on
the on the sample so say say I used the
median to estimate the expectation of a
distribution so if that distribution is
symmetric the median is an unbiased
estimator if it's a symmetric it's
biased so assume that this is the median
okay and I want to and theta represents
the expectation of my distribution so
this is going to be biased given that
this distribution is asymmetric so what
I do is I take what I had from the data
and then I simulate
from the distribution I assume for my
DEXA so say I'm saying my data is
exponential I simulate from that
distribution using a parameter theta K
minus one so this is going to be I as
the name says ID rusev so it's the
previous solution and basically I'm
going to simulate based on the previous
solution and compute my zero estimator
and then basically what I'm doing is
trying to find the theta that makes
these guys as close as possible and I do
that nitrated fashion okay and the
starting PI can be my initial biased Phi
so I can start with a median plug it
here then I simulate from an exponential
distribution whose mean whose
expectation is going to be equal to my
previous median simulate from that and
compute my median again so this is the
expectation of my median given that I'm
simulating from what it should should be
estimating do that and then I basically
continue doing it until I converge so
until my my steps are within a certain
distance and it has shown that this
procedure can correct finite sample and
asymptotic bias and the very general
conditions so in in the privacy setting
my guess is that we one can use a
differentially private biased output so
often when you introduce noise you can
bias the resulting outputs and therefore
in order to improve the accuracy from
the outputs one can use this mechanism
and indeed I use it within the
simulation study we'll see in a few
moments
another another procedure which I won't
go into details about is the inference
procedure so you can correct the bias
and now how do you perform tests on your
data if you're if I'm interested to
perform tests on my differentiy right
outputs how can I perform the inference
well yet according to the type of
problem or a differential privates
algorithm this can be quite complex
complex to do so already in a assuming
that's all you have a result Gaussian
Zeta and adding noise then it's going to
be it's already quite complicated this
this algorithm is basically based on
indirect inference which is what
inspires the items in bootstrap and
basically by putting H equals 1 and then
repeating this procedure B times what
you get is a distribution of my
estimator and but and it's it's some way
it has very similar properties to
approximate bayesian computing so this
is a very low cost inference method that
can be a can be used I haven't used it
for these preliminary results but this
is a future Avenue on investigation yes
trying to rewrite re-weight in any way
the sample points you have because once
you once you did one iteration even now
you have some estimation about which
ones are the in layers and outliers
it's it's for each pair point it's
either this or that so they're like
equivalent algorithm like I owe this and
stuff that try to achieve a similar
thing via yes so there is the ITER
acidity well for example robust
statistics it to solve many of these
core function for example linear
regression they use the isolated Leary
weighted least squares problems so a
d-types
iteration you you wait you're the
observations you can Poots your estimate
again and then and until convergence
that's true so in this case what what
that does it finds you a point estimate
so say I want my beaches for for a
certain problem so for linear regression
problem well that gives you a solution
so it gives you the points and the
values but now say I am a researcher and
I want
you understand if that value actually
contributes to explaining my data so
should I keep this variable in my data
should I use it or not I need a
distribution for my Vitas right so that
procedure and it's exactly what it's
used in robust statistic that gives you
the points now I need to understand how
they behave to understand if it if it
can be close to zero or not and so this
procedure that is a pretty much quite
simple scenario simple but there can be
very complex settings where this guy is
analytically intractable and so this
procedure allows you to give you a
distribution for my estimator that's a
very well a little computational cost
okay so this is another another avenue
of research that can be done yeah yeah
yeah so this sort of setup requires that
you be recovering like a generative
generative model for the data exactly
yeah so so that's one of the limit a
possible limitations that I I want to
turn the line regarding this philosophy
of robust statistics so you're always
assuming in general that there's a
generative model for your data well I
guess I mean as opposed to say a
regression problem where you're
recovering just sort of some part of the
crop of the jiggers of model like namely
the you know the link between the so
it's just saying thing you're trying to
predict so basically well so so for the
for the beaters so you're saying for a
regression problem my interest is
finding the the parameters of the
beaters
speculations yet for linear regression
yeah use the coefficients but then it's
not clear this type of how to apply this
type of approach right so you can't you
don't have a generative model for the
entire data set yes exactly
so that's that's exactly what I was I
what I meant is the limitation of this
is that for a bus statistics you're
assuming for example at your residuals
so you have your beaters plus an error
right and that error has a certain
parametric distribution so say it's a
normal it's a Gaussian then it has mean
X beta and variance Sigma Sigma squared
so the idea is in that case now you can
work with this so say say you use simple
in your regression to estimate the
beaters from a logistic regression where
you're trying to classify between 0 and
1
this procedure can allow to correct the
bias because you're not solving a linear
equation there so it's basically you're
maybe you can use a problem but of
course you have to have a full fully
specified parametric setting so you're
estimating a model including your noise
because that's what allows you to
generate and then you can D by sitting
that your Y given the
distributing which is the equivalent to
assuming the air has a normal
distribution so there is a generative
distribution in certain Federation but I
guess you you're assuming that you have
sort of hey I'm thinking maybe maybe
I'll save my question for later I'm
thinking in the context of hydro
post-processing okay you like using this
in the context of regression means like
you're your conditioning on the design
matrix right yeah right but in the
context of sort of post-processing the
output of a differentially private
algorithm you don't you don't have the
design matrix sitting there it's sort of
behind the you know you don't have
direct access to it anyway so okay yeah
so it's true that when it comes to
privacy then you yeah you need the the
matrix the X's that's true you would
need the X's and so in that case you
would be assuming that those X's are you
can share but of course that's not sa a
case so for the moment so these are as I
said as new to privacy so these are
limitations I'm conscious of that there
can be for example you can assume a
generative model for your and it can
only be approximate for your axes you
just say give it a distribution for each
of the x's and a joint and you and you
can I can and you can do this and you
can correct in case the user wants to
say okay I don't think my this X was
exponential or a Gaussian I'm going to
find the parameter of that X by by
changing that but it's true that's a
limitation yeah
any other questions okay well I'll just
skip I'll just roughly go to the
simulations so it's a very simple
setting we want to our school function
is the school function for the location
parameter and so we want to estimate the
mean of the distribution and and then we
use the hueber function as a real
function so the the bounded function we
saw earlier and what another idea is
what the although the limitation is
speccing specifying a fully a full
generative model what it does is that by
choosing this tuning constant K you
don't necessarily you don't have to
bound the the parameter space in many
cases you don't have to bound the
parameter space nor the the dayses so
you're not truncating the data and so we
want to see the impact of this tuning
constant when it comes to statistical
accuracy of the differentiating private
output so we just use ideas okay
can a robust mechanism with bias
correction improve over be used within
existing differential privacy mechanisms
and can it improve physical access
accuracy so we we just use objective
perturbation as one of the privacy
mechanism and so I'm I'm not sure I've
I'm guessing everyone it's aware of it
so I won't go through it so we use this
and we just consider a simple setting
where in all cases we assume Sigma is
known although as increased or we can
extend it to the place to estimating
Sigma but for all cases we assume Sigma
is known and we have a sample mean of
three we have different sample sizes of
101,000 and three levels of privacy
budget and we make this tuning constant
vary between 0.5 and 2 which is the
range usually defined for the tuning
constant of a hooba
function so these are commonly known and
so we're just studying what the range is
for this problem okay so we compare so
two in order to say okay how good are
these privacy mechanisms with respect to
the underlying estimator we want so we
use as reference the sample mean okay so
and the robust mean so in this case the
robust mean is not biased because it's a
symmetric the normal is symmetric and
then we have five different well no
sorry it's a six different kind of
objective perturbation mechanisms so the
first four are based on truncating my my
data in order to have these these
perturbation mechanisms or parameters so
we we have different forms of education
quite good truncation so we're around
the mean precisely around the mean and a
good vicinity of it a very large one and
then small bias truncations on one side
or the other and then we have objective
participation applied to there directly
to the robust estimator with the who
beside function and then we have the
bias corrected robust one because this
one when you perturb it is biased and
therefore we apply the I to receive
bootstrap to correct for that bias okay
so just one additional thing we have in
in their simulations we had different
points that were quite lying outside so
we decided to you booth use a robust
measure of the mean squared error based
on the median and yet mean absolute
deviation okay so what do we see here so
I use the log of the mean squared error
because to the distances were otherwise
squashing everything together so what we
see here is the blue
is the mean squared error of the sample
mean okay and as we expect it should be
performing very well okay
the robust estimator so sorry this is
for that say sample size equals 100 and
pricey budget 0.1 so the robust
estimator also lies pretty close to it
there is an advantage of the robust
estimator when the model is correctly
specified meaning that it's cutting off
observations where they become more
variable and therefore it can improve in
terms of mean squared error and then
here these these constant lines of
course
sorry on the x-axis we see the K the
tuning constant that we make vary
between 0.5 and 2 for robustness so the
only ones that are supposed to change
with this tuning constants are the
robust one this brown line which is the
perturbed robust one and this one being
the bias corrected robust one okay the
other lines you see here are the other
for objective participation methods okay
so what we see at least for epsilon
equals 0.1 the tuning constant K as as
this increases it's it starts going back
up but in any case with we're lying
below in terms of statistical accuracy
it's improving over most of the range of
of K same thing for epsilon one where
now we're going up so so they're all
improving of course because the privacy
budget has gone down and here we see
that it's it's going back up but not as
deeply as before and when epsilon equals
two it's it's still going down here so
I'm sure I'm assuming I didn't try it
but as K goes on it'll go on further up
later so there's a kind of trade-off
between the epsilon privacy budget and
the K but in any case we're doing better
than the than the the best possible
truncation
we have okay so well there's sample a
same message for sample sizes equal one
thousand so that's all basically just
skip skip those and go to the conclusion
so basically what we see is that despite
the tuning constant having a range we
can we can manage to keep at least in
the this very simple simulation setting
we can perform at least as well as the
best truncation on data without and
being very flexible on the K and that
allows us to and this framework allows
us to avoid putting a strength arbitrary
truncations on the data which can lead
to possible problems with inference
there is there is a role that can be
played and it can be studied between the
tuning parameters okay
and the privacy bots budget Epsilon okay
so that can be studied and so we can
understand the trade-off between utility
and privacy based on this relationship
and these these simulations were also
made on defining the exponential
distribution with similar conclusions so
the limitations as we are discussing
earlier
it needs a fully paralyzed setting and a
well defined score function whose
expectation is 0 and the tuning constant
K can also depend on the scale of my my
problem so I'm assuming it has less
assumptions to be made on the scale on
the problem rather than the range of my
data and we still need to it's if the
routines such as items to be really
weighted least squares can be used in a
private manner and so we're looking into
the exponential reckon isms are using
turkey by weight function and this has
possibly got some good results there and
so the direction is to see these these
correction and inference mechanisms how
they can be applied to directly to
differentially pride
two outputs and understand how
robustness can be used within the other
existing differentially private
mechanisms so yeah that's it
thank you very much for one question so
the the horror function is not second or
very differentiable yes to apply
objective for a vision in the Hessians
so it doesn't have a so to my to my
knowledge for objective translation it
doesn't it needs to be almost everywhere
if also you need a really ambitious yeah
so it should be okay okay so you might
take any other questions to the great
clubs thing for rotor again